le sans plomb dépasse à nouveau les deux
euros le litre le gazole san approche
dangereusement et cela malgré la remise
de 18 centimes par litre mise en place
par l'état depuis le 1er avril et nous
continuerons de protéger contre
l'inflation tant qu'elle durera tant
qu'elles désirent un oui tant qu'elle
durera après on ferait évoluer des
dispositifs en fonction des chiffres de
l'inflation mais aujourd'hui on est dans
le pic il propose plein de choses comme
ça rapidement à la va vite pour essayer
de maintenir leur majorité au parlement
c'est bon signe pour nous ça veut dire
que cette panique révèle le fait qu'ils
ne sont pas sûrs d'avoir la majorité et
que nous nous pouvons la gagner 0 chance
enfin je veux dire il a il a moins de
chances d'être premier ministre que moi
de gagner au loto sont jouées ce sera un
échec programmé pour tous ce camp parce
que les
présidents du rassemblement national et
les gens de l air n'ont pas voulu de
l'accord global il ya la façon dont on
peut vous accompagner pour que vous
puissiez peut-être reprendre une
activité professionnelle
j'imagine que c'est quelque chose que
vous pourriez souhaiter des techno
résume françois ruffin pour marine le
pen la réaction glaciale d'elisabeth
bang traduit la politique injuste et
inhumaine et méprisante des manuels
macron
professionnel avait complété par au
fauteuil
et surtout à gauche que ça cogne à la
brutalité de ce gouvernement n'a pas de
limites soupira clémence gaieté glacial
insensible renchérit fabien roussel
peut-être c'est pas le moment de parler
de cette hypothèse de reprise de
l'activité profession à un panier déjà
vous accompagner exane est borgne
humilie par erreur ou par goût pour
l'interrogation un million
d'allocataires chômage savent quelle
heure a fait les poches ici à l'humilie
une femme en fauteuil des policiers ont
tué hier une femme de 21 ans et de fait
c'est pas la première fois s'il ya
cédric joue bien il y en a d'autres et
et l'enjeu c'est qu'elle ne tue plus il
est tout à fait en dehors mais quand il
a fait sa course poursuite il a tué
personne il ya aux personnes dans la rue
qui a été blessée ont renversé je suis
triste aussi du fait que
père d'une amie devant moi et après on
va se battre pour la justice on a un
problème qui est que l'igpn est à
l'intérieur de la police et qu'il nous
faut sortir cette igpn pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des enquêtes qui
soient totalement indépendante après
orpea 30 plaintes sont déposées
aujourd'hui contre le groupe de maisons
de retraite korian des plaintes contre x
qui ont été déposés par dix-huit
familles de résidents dans plusieurs
villes françaises à la mémoire de notre
collègue et ami frédéric leclerc imhof
je vous demande de respecter une minute
de silence
qu'est ce que la russie a déjà réussi à
vendre de tout ce qui a été volé en
ukraine à part les céréales
alors je vous parle de vous les
ukrainiens vous êtes toujours préoccupé
de ce que vous pouvez voler et où est
devenu professeur et vous pensez que
tous les ans comme ça mais ça je ne
postez pas dmitri medvedev
sur télé grave messagerie privée je les
déteste ce sont des bâtards et des
dégénérés il vole à mort pour nous pour
la russie et tant que je vivrai je ferai
tout pour les faire disparaître
images qui nous viennent de suisse
michel platini qui arrivent au tribunal
l'ancien président de l'uefa sectionné
d'escroquerie est jugé à partir
d'aujourd'hui des bouteilles de moët et
chandon qui présente effectivement des
traces d'ecstasy c'est la répression des
fraudes qui alertent ya aussi une alerte
qui a été lancé en belgique et en
allemagne à les premières sont apparus
au mois de mars françois hollande et
julie gayet se sont dit oui l'ancien
président de la république et l'actrice
se sont mariés samedi dans l'intimité à
tulle en corrèze vous les voyez elles
sont opaques en fait on peut se rend
compte de rien avant d'avoir fait sauter
le bouchon est comme un allemand qui en
a bu au restaurant et qui en est mort en
train déraillé ce matin en iran dans le
centre du pays au moins dix personnes
ont été tuées et une douzaine d'autres
blessés mexique avec l'inauguration à
nîmes pour suspendu qui a tourné
vraiment au fiasco assez simple le fonds
a craqué au moment du passage des
invités de l'inauguration